the people of the village of mukundi
bury the bodies of dozens of children
women and men killed in an attack by an
armed group it's not the first time
they've had to do this
it was evening around seven o'clock I
heard noises and children starting to
flee suddenly the rebels were attacking
in the direction of our health center
they were shouting the children shouted
the ADF Rebels are here
the Army says the ADF or Allied
Democratic forces is responsible it's
widely blamed for killing thousands of
civilians in aturi Province over the
last decade
as you see in mukundi it's always the
same ADF which always has bad intentions
towards the Congolese so they showed up
here in the village of mukundi we lost
many of our brothers
two years ago the government declared a
state of Siege here a form of Martial
law it said it would enable a Crackdown
on the armed groups but the attacks have
only become more frequent and more
bloody
here three or four days don't go by
without us recording deaths the result
of barbarity from ADF terrorists that is
why once again we repeat we need
considerable military force to come that
can contribute to the restoration of
Peace
the ADF originally came from neighboring
Uganda in the 1990s the armies of both
Uganda and Congo have pledged to defeat
them but rights groups say the military
operations haven't helped and the
violence against civilians is growing
worse
Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera